this is a bit sneaky they give you three
points but then they they I should take
I I haven't drawn a set of axes like I
did here okay so you need to think about
and this is tricky where would be a good
set of axes okay so have a look at the
numbers you've got 4 negative 5 that
means go across and then down yes
negative 2 1 that means go to the left
and up and then 33 so I'm going to try
and draw a set of axes kind in the
middle like this that looks pretty close
to the middle right yeah not acceptable
ah maybe it isn't there isn't a medal
for the heart for this one I don't be
but that's close enough okay so you got
zero your y-axis your x-axis so again
I'm going to do this in order for
negative 5 again that's my x value my Y
value okay so when x is for that means
go across 1 2 3 4 and y equals negative
five beads go down 1 2 3 4 5 there is
right there your [ __ ] is through up for
months okay it's a good idea it's a good
idea um because then you can tell the
points apart you don't get confused b is
negative 2 that's negative 1 2 i'm going
to the left and one so there you go and
last one Corey I think it's a good idea
where you can like sometimes if you got
lots of lots of points flying around
maybe you want to avoid putting on so
much information but I'm just going to
draw a triangle on a second it's pretty
simple I last point 3 3 so 1 2 3 1 2 3
there you go yes see
okay now you'll know if you got it right
or not by the last step which is it says
don't just plot the points it says draw
the triangle ok so I'm going to join
these guys up like so there's a see
there's a bee there's BCD go so your
triangle water look something like that
okay now there was something a bit
sneaky I'll just get this piece of paper
here because I've got to the next page
right if you have a look it's nice
looking at all these other things but
you might notice the three coordinates
they give you it's that it's the same
coordinates right so you can actually
use the diagram you did before to help
you out okay so here's what i'm going to
do i'm just going to have this diagram
here just off on the side while i refer
to these questions here okay so find
that it is a sin city find in fact it
says you know since the points are right
like it's talking about and this is part
be following on from part a so it's all
one question find the court it's about
the midpoint of a B and a marketing or a
diagram ok now we're going to do this
precisely but in a second before we do
that you have a look at this light a B
you can actually if you had a ruler you
could get it out and you can say well it
looks like it's about see Timmy's mom
right I think it's gonna be here I
expect it to be there okay now that's
just roughly approximating it let's
crunch the numbers and see if it worked
out okay so here's what I've got what is
the midpoint formula does anyone
remember keep it clue starts with these
big brackets bracket X yes next 10
before before I do by x1 too far over
white plus x2 is the bit put this is the
best reason what we learnt and then I
divide by 2 because I'm taking the
average and then you do the same thing
for the wise like so okay so I've got my
X's and Y's now I'm going to label them
up here
these are the two points of interested
in so i'll call that X Y and Y also y1
and x2 y2 like sir ok so now all I need
to do is press it with these particular
values so i get 4 plus negative 2 um and
negative 5 plus 1 okay you guys can help
me out four plus negative 2 what's that
that's two over two good which is one
right and it's minus minus 5 plus 1
what's minus 5 plus 1 that's minus for
you / to idea right gives you negative 2
now does that check out the other look
that looks right look see one across and
two down sure enough it's 1 negative 2 I
did it okay well done any questions on
that does anyone be clarify any steps
just just okay I'll try to remember okay
you calculate the gradient of your like
bc okay so i need the gradient that's a
lowercase M right what's the great
formula rise over run very good that's
excellent now what are the XO why is the
correspond to that one Rises about the Y
values right so I'm going to have y2
minus y1 over and then runs about the X
values yeah x2 minus x1 yeah yeah okay
so let's have a look here are points
right I'll just write them over here
just so I can see them right next to
each other right there you go so y2
minus y1 i'm going to go 3-1 like so and
then run is three minus now watch out
for the double negative like so 3 minus
1 is 2 what's the denominator three
minus negative 2 what's that
I think that spy design yes double
negative equals a fun now just check
that out to Fitz does that look about
right yeah look see it goes the rise the
rise here is two units and the run like
that is five units right right everyone
two and five for sure okay what was
their calculate the distance AC all
right this is the whole awkward formula
distance AC I give you clear it's got
that square root sign what's underneath
the square root yeah yeah it's the same
as these guys right except there cuz
from Pythagoras there they squared right
so I'm gonna write it like this squared
and the x's square okay so this comes
from Pythagoras right so now I look at
my numbers I've got my arm my a is for
negative 5 + by C is 33 you can see I
keep on writing the court it's every
time so I knew which ones I prefer you
to and I don't mix them up that's really
easy to meet analysis okay here's the Y
values so square root off 3 minus
negative 5 3 minus nine to five and then
this will be 3-4 what's three base they
253 nice minus negative as a double
negative so it'll be three plus five
which is a well done eight squared 3
minus 4 is negative one so when you
square it what happens negative 1 times
negative 1 the negatives cancel each
other yeah so it's just gonna become bad
okay just one all right so damn almost
finished 8 x 8 8 squared what's that
equal to 64 very good plus 1 64 + 165 is
65 2 squared number no no it's not did
they ask you to approximate not so you
just you just say units done
okay which would be like 8.1 or some
kind of a point to something like that
but that's that's it yeah it's right
exactly right you don't if okay laughs
step determine the rule or equation of
the line a B now let me just put it on
the picture again a be that's up that's
this slide here right okay so how are we
going to do it this is this is my Betty
Betty lions okay oh we need to patients
with you to pieces I need a wider steps
that's that's this one here and I did be
gradient why does have to regret it so
kick you read off like I've done it one
green squares one unit so what would
that value be it's just one below the
origin yeah so should be negative one
very good okay so that's my y-intercept
I'll just tuck that away now what's the
gradient this is a trickier what's the
greynium we work out graded by rise over
run yeah rise over right now I go from
left to right so what's the rise the
it's actually going down isn't it you
see that so for example the rise you
might say okay how about negative 2 from
here to here that's negative 2 right so
the run that corresponds to that is to
write so its rise is negative 2 and run
is too can you see that okay so
therefore let me come back to hear you
already told me that the y-intercept is
equal to negative 1 and the gray it is
rise over run which you top is negative
2 over 2 what's that's it fight it
that's negative negative 1 right okay so
I need to put these two together this
guy and this guy it's nice and
convenient that they're the same okay
i'm going to put them into this form do
you recognize this right there's an
eMeter be which ones which that's the
gradient and that's the y-intercept in
this case because the numbers are
actually the same does matter but
usually they'll be different
you put the graded here and the way to
set here in this case I get negative X
minus and expiry